[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم ليلى الشخلي
في الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى والبدايه من تل ابيب والمشهد
بعد ساعات فقط من اقرار قانون في الكنيست
نقلص من صلاحياتي المحكمه العليا في
اسرائيل
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وايضا الان الى نيويورك وتحديدا مبنى
الامم المتحده ومنه صدر تصريح عن المتحدث
باسم منظمه الدوليه يقول فيه ان اكثر من
اربعين في المئه من سكان السودان اي اكثر
من 19 مليون شخص يواجهون اليوم الجوع بسبب
الصراع الدائر منذ اكثر من مئه يوم
والى موسكو التي تعرضت بحسب تاكيدات روسيه
لهجوم بالمسيرات استهدف مبنيين الهجوم
والثاني من نوعه خلال الشهر الجاري روسيا
حملت اوكرانيا المسؤوليه ووصفت الهجوم
بالارهابي
وفي مواضيع الحسد هذه الليله
بعد اقرار الكنيست باندا الرئيسيا في خطه
التغييرات القضائيه المثيره للجدل
احتجاجات رافضه وصدامات بين الشرطه
ومتظاهرين عشرات من طياري الاحتياط ابلغوا
قادتهم رفض الخدمه تهديدات بالاضراب
والمعارضه تؤكد اعتزامها الطعن امام
المحكمه العليا ونتنياهو يدعو للحوار
ويشدد على ان الاجراء يعيد التوازن بين
السلطات
بعد هجوم بمسيرات على موسكو وشبه جزيره
القرم روسيا تتهم اوكرانيا وتقول انها
تحتفظ لنفسها بحق اتخاذ اجراءات رد قاسيه
وبعد هجمات متتاليه على ميناء اوديسا
اوكرانيا تتهم روسيا باستهداف طريق رئيسي
لتصدير الحبوب الاوكرانيه عبر الدنو
وفي المشهد الميداني في السودان انفجارات
في شمالي ام درمان الطائرات الحربيه للجيش
تحلق بكثافه في سماء العاصمه والامم
المتحده تقول ان اكثر من تسعه ملايين
سوداني يواجهون شبح الجوع بسبب القتال
الدائري منذ اكثر من 100 يوم
وفي لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا التداعيات المحتمله لاقرار
الكنيست التغييرات القضائيه في اسرائيل
ووصف اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن ما
حدث في الكنيست بالامر المؤسر ودعوتها
قاده اسرائيل
للتوافق من خلال الحوار السياسي لاستطلاع
ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا طرحنا عليكم
هذا السؤال برايكم ما هي ابرز التداعيات
المحتمله لاقرار الكنيست التغييرات
القضائيه في اسرائيل الاجابات جاءت على
النحو التالي نحو 70% قالوا انهم يترقبون
ارتفاع منسوب التوتر الاجتماعي والانقسام
في اسرائيل بينما صوت قرابه
23% لصالح القول ان ذلك سيؤدي الى ازمه
داخل الجيش مع التزايد موجه العصيان ورفض
الخدمه العسكريه في حين فضل نحو سبعه في
المئه خي اضعافي علاقات اسرائيل مع الدول
الغربيه الحليفه لها هذا السؤال سيبقى
مطروحا في منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الذي
يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقائنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
ونتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله
عربيا ودويا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
في حرائق الغابات بالجزائر عدد الضحايا
يرتفع الى 34 قتيلا بينهم 10 من افراد
الجيش وتونس تتاهب بعد اندلاع حريق في
غابات جندوبه
[موسيقى]
اقر الكنيسه الاسرائيليه اول قانون في
حزمه التغييرات القضائيه باغلبيه 64 سلطا
بعد القراءتين الثانيه والثالثه والانتهاء
من التصويت على تحفظات المعارضه على
تغييرات التي تضع قيودا على صلاحيات
المحكمه العليا هذا وكان وزير الدفاع من
بين المصوتين لصالح التغييرات القضائيه
ووصف وزير العدل الاسرائيلي يعرف لافين
التصويت بالخطوه الاولى في عمليه تاريخيه
لاصلاح النظام القضائي في اسرائيل يعد هذا
القانون واحدا من مجموعه قوانين ترى فيها
المعارضه انقلابا على النظام القائم
ين المتطرف الحاكم في اسرائيل حقق غايته
وبدا باحكام سيطرته على مراكز القوه
ممثلوها الاربعه وستون وهم الاغلبيه في
الكنيست حسبوا المعركه على قانون الغاء
ذريعه المعقوديه لصالحهم وبذلك حيدوا
المحكمه العليا عن التدخل في قرارات
وجرائهم المتطرفين
انا مسرور جدا اننا اسرارنا على هذا
القانون وانا مسرور لاننا في هذا اليوم
حققنا الخطوه الاولى وهذه البدايه فقط
هذا القانون واحد من حزمه ترى فيها
المعارضه انقلابا على النظام
نحن في طريقنا الى الكارثه التصويت على
هذا القانون يقرب نهايه جيش الشعب ويعزز
اعداءنا ويلحق الضرر بدوله اسرائيل
لا غرابه اذا ان يرى المعارضون في الشارع
بعد 29 اسبوعا من المظاهرات فيه يوما اسود
ليس لدي كلمه اقولها هذه كارثه نحن حزينون
جدا هذا يوم اسود
ماذا انتم فاعلون سالنا احد قاده حركه
اخوه السلاح التي تحشد العصيان داخل قوات
الاحتياط في الجيش الذي اعلن الالاف منهم
الامتناع عن الخدمه
الكنيست وسنواصل الحرب اسرائيل اقوى من
هذا البلطجي الذي سينهي حياته في السجن
نزل الغاضبون الى الشارع واغلقوا العديد
من المحاور في مناطق مختلفه حيث لم تتردد
الشرطه في قمعهم
ترى المعارضه ان المصالح الخاصه التقت مع
المصالح الايديولوجيه وان اليمين المتطرفه
في اسرائيل حقق مراده تمهيدا لتخليص
نتنياهو من محاكماته وعوده درع الى
الوزاره وحسم الصراع مع الفلسطينيين وهكذا
يبدو ان اسرائيل تدخل مرحله اشد خطوره من
كل سابقاتها وليد العمري الجزيره القدس
الغربيه
من الناصره ينضم الان الينا ايهاب جبارين
الباحث المختص بالشان الاسرائيلي اهلا
وسهلا بك في الحصاد اذا حتى ونحن نتكلم
الان الاحتجاجات مستمره في اسرائيل ولكن
في النهايه نتنياهو وقف في وجه العاصفه
وانتصر على الاقل في الوقت الحالي
ماذا سيحصل في على ماذا سيحصل في المقابل
ما هي المكاسب
نعم مساء الخير بدون نتنياهو يعني هذا اهم
بذره يمكن القول انها كان يريد الحصول
عليها من هذه الحكومه وليس فقط من هذه
الحكومه بل منذ دخوله الى المعترك
الانتخابي في المرحله الثانيه يعني عندما
عاد اليها بالحكم في 2009 بدون ادنى شك ان
نتنياهو الذي ربما يسوق ذاته بعض الشيء
وكانه
رهينه بيد الصهيونيه الدينيه وبيد
المستوطنين شركائه في هذا الحكومه ولكن
يجب ان نتذكر في نهايه المطاف بين يمين
نتنياهو وشريك ايديولوجي لسبوتش
ولكل هذه الشريحه من العنصريه اللهم انه
يختلف بينه عنهم فقط بشيء واحد هو
بالاستراتيجيه والتكتيك بالنسبه اليهم هم
يريدون كل شيء كن فيكون الان لا يابهون
لاعتبارات للمحكمه ولا للقضاء ولا لاي
اعتبارات خارجيه حتى هو ياخذ هذه المعايير
بعين الاعتبار بعض ولكن
يدرك جيدا انه من اجل تقييد ومن اجل تقييد
صلاحيات المحكمه في كل ما يخص الاستيطان
وفي كل ما يخص اخذ اسرائيل الى المرحله
الثانيه هو بحاجه لبعض التقييدات ولهذا
السبب هو بدا بهذا الان نتنياهو في هذه
المرحله بشكل رسمي سوف يبدا يمهد لاسرائيل
في مرحلتها الثانيه وان شئنا ان نسمي ذلك
بمسمياتها الاخرى اسرائيل عام 67 بكلمات
اخرى اسرائيل المؤسسه عام 48 مؤسسيها
حافظوا عليها على معايير معينه لاقت
استحسان الغرب بمفاهيمك هذه او كاخرى
واعطوا المستوطنين اعطوا جمهور المستوطنين
بالمناسبه ان يقوموا بكل ما يقوموا به ان
يديروا دوله بالكامل بداخل الضفه الغربيه
او حتى في قطاع غزه في مرحله معينه ضمن
دونما التدخل في امور
المحتله عام 48 الاحسان لم يعد موجود الان
ما يحاول ان يقوم به بنيامين نتنياهو ان
بالضبط بالضبط ويحاول ان يبسط سيطره هذا
اليمين على كامل اراضي فلسطين المحتله
عام ثمانيه
انسان انقلب انتقادا كبيرا ليس فقط في
الداخل وانما في الخارج ايضا
والتحدي كبير الى متى سيستمر في هذا
التعويل على حلفائه الايديولوجيين الذين
كما يبدو يقدمهم على اي مصلحه اخرى ام هي
مصلحته الشخصيه لكي ينجوا من حبل المغسله
هذا هو الهدف الاساسي بالنسبه له
بدون ان نشاك هنالك معيار اثنين لهذه
التعديلات المعيار الاول بالنسبه لبنيه هو
شخصي وباليمين نتنياهو منذ عام 2018 يختلف
كليا عما كان قبل ذلك في هذه المرحله لديه
الكثير من الاعتبارات المعايير الشخصيه
ويفضل نفسه بمفاهيم كهذه او اخرى حتى فوق
اسرائيل التي اعطاها الكثير يمكن القول من
وقته ومن حياته المهنيه ولكن وعلى الرغم
من كل ذلك وبعيدا عن المعيار الشخصي ان
يبتعد عن المقصله مقصله القضاء هنالك بدون
ادنى شك معايير للاديولوجيا معايير
للشركاء الايديولوجيين في نهايه المطاف
هنالك مراحل يجب ان يقدمها وان يستمر بها
وليس هذا فقط وهي النقطه يجب الوقوف عندها
في نهايه المطاف عندما عاد بيجن الى الحكم
او عفوا عندما دخل الى الحكم للمره الاولى
وابسط قبضه اليمين على الحكم للمره الاولى
بيجن لم يقم بذلك الانقلاب الابيض وهذا
ربما هناك الكثير من الماخذ عليه لهذه
النقطه
استمر واعطى اليسار بان يدير هذه الحكومه
او الشريحه المؤسسه بان تدير هذه الدوله
بكل صلاحياتها ان كان في
المناصب العليا في الوزارات في الجيش
وغيرها الان نتنياهو يريد ان يقوم بهذا
الانقلاب الابيض وان يبسط سيطره نفوذ
اليمين بالكامل على كل مناطق
داخل الدوله العميقه لاسرائيل الجيش
والوزاره ايهاب جبارين سؤال الاهم بنظري
بالشان الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا لك وهذا هو
السؤال ربما سننقله لضيفتنا من واشنطن
الباحثه في برنامج الشرق الاوسط بالمجلس
الاطلسي اهلا وسهلا بك في الحصاد اذا كان
فعلا نتنياهو عينه على هذا الانقلاب
الابيض على ماذا يعول وهو يتعرض لكل هذا
الضغط من الداخل ومن الخارج ايضا
كما تفضلتم
بالحديث ان الكنيسه صوت على هذه الاصلاحات
القضائيه التي واجهها مئات الالاف من
الاسرائيليين في مظاهرات في الشوارع لا
نتحدث هنا عن انقلاب بل نتحدث عن ازمه
هناك تغييرات اساسيه تودع الحكومه
الاسرائيليه ان تنفذها والديمقراطيه
الاسرائيليه لم تتعرض لذلك من قبل اذا ان
نتنياهو يود ان يحافظ على مصالح الائتلاف
الحكومي الذي يدعم الاصلاحات اذا هناك
مظاهرات في الشوارع والتي لا تدعم هكذا
التغييرات على مستوى
الحكم في اسرائيل ولكن من الاهميه بمكان
ان نتذكر ان بنيامين نتنياهو قام بذلك من
خلال المسار القانوني ومره هذا التعديل
عبر الكنيست وهناك تحديات على مستوى
المجتمع الاسرائيلي وطبعا هناك محاولات
لعكس نتيجه هذا التصويت اذا كان على هذا
الائتلاف الحاكم في هذه المرحله
السؤال كيف ينظر العالم والطالما ارادت
اسرائيل واراد نتنياهو تحديدا ان يسوق
للعالم ان اسرائيل دوله ديمقراطيه اسرائيل
دوله مؤسسات الان كيف ينظر العالم لما
يجري في اسرائيل حاليا
كنا نتحدث عن الداخل الاسرائيلي ولكن
نتحدث الان عن الولايات المتحده عن الغرب
اسرائيل
لطالما صورت نفسها على انها اقدم
ديمقراطيه واقدر ديمقراطيه استقرارا في
منطقه الشرق الاوسط طبعا حلفاء اسرائيل من
الديمقراطيات من الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه الى اوروبا لديهم بواعد قلق
اساسيه ولكن في الوقت نفسه شاهدنا تاكلا
للديمقراطيه في كل انحاء العالم بما في
ذلك في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبالتالي الاساس الذي بنيت عليه العلاقه
بين اسرائيل والدول الاخرى لن يتاثر نتيجه
لما يحصل ما يحصل في اسرائيل الان يشكل
تحديات وهناك تداعيات على مستقبل اسرائيل
واقتصاد اسرائيل والامن القومي ولكن هناك
تبعات اقل على مستوى السياسه الخارجيه
الباحثه في برنامج الشرق الاوسط
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا
ونتابع تفاصيل تداعيات التغييرات القضائيه
في التقرير التالي
في دوله لا دستور فيها المحكمه العليا في
اسرائيل وجهه السياسيين والمشرعين
للاحتكام اليها تؤدي دورا ناظما بين
السلطات وهكذا فان التغييرات التي يدعمها
تيار اقصى اليمين تثير مخاوف من تداعياتها
فالمحكمه العليا تشكل جوهر الخلاف في
التغييرات حيث تؤدي دورا في حفظ التوازن
السياسي مع غياب اي دستور لاسرائيل
تنظر المحكمه العليا في القضايا كافه ضد
السلطات الدوله ودستوريه القوانين لذلك
فان احد الاهداف الاساسيه للتغيير القضائي
هو تمكين الحكومه من التحكم في اصدار
القوانين وتمرير التشريعات سواء التي
ابطلتها المحكمه في السابق او التي سوف
تمرر مستقبلا بموافقه اغلبيه بسيطه من
اعضاء الكنيست تشمل خطه التغييرات
القضائيه منحى اعضاء الكنيست نفوذا اوسع
في لجنه تعيين قضاه المحكمه العليا بزياده
عدد اعضاء اللجنه وسط مخاوف من ان يعلو
صوت السياسيين منهم على صوت التكنوقرات او
اهل الاختصاص ويراد من التغييرات ايضا
حمايه بنيامين نتنياهو وحلفائه لاسيما حزب
شاس وزعيمه اريا درعي في مشكلاتهم
القانونيه
وقضايا الفساد والاحتيال بسن قوانين تمنع
تنحيه رئيس الوزراء من منصبه
وهناك طريقتان لفعل ذلك
تنحي رئيس الوزراء بنفسه بابلاغ الكنيست
او تنحيه الحكومه باغلبيه ثلاثه ارباع
وزرائها وتاييد الكنيست باغلبيه 90 عضوا
[موسيقى]
سرايا القدس الجناح العسكري لحركه الجهاد
الاسلاميه ان السلطه الفلسطينيه ما زالت
تعتقل احد عشر من اعضاءها في الضفه وترفض
كل المطالب بالافراج عنهم واشارت سرايا
القدس في بيان الى نقل المعتقل مراد مليشه
الى المستشفى بعد تدهور وضعه الصحي جراء
الاعتقال كما حملت سرايا القدس الاجهزه
الامنيه الفلسطينيه المسؤوليه عن حياه
المعتقلين في سجونها في الضفه الغربيه
ووصفت استمرار الاعتقال السياسي وملاحقه
اعضائها بانه خدمه مجانيه تقدمها السلطه
الفلسطينيه للاحتلال الاسرائيلي
[موسيقى]
ولان الى تطورات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا
اذ اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اسقاط
مسيرتين اوكرانيتين في العاصمه موسكو
بينما شددت الخارجيه على حق روسيا بالرد
اجراءات قاسيه على ما وصفته بالعمل
الارهابي وقد اعترفت اوكرانيا بالهجوم
قائله انه كان عمليه خاصه نفذها جهاز
الاستخبارات العسكريه التابع لوزاره
الدفاع في الاثناء اعلنت سلطات القرم
المواليه لروسيا اسقاط مسيرات استهدفت
مستودعا للذخائر في شبه جزيره القرن
العاصمه الروسيه مجددا في المرمى
الاوكراني هذه المره على نحو اوسع واشد
فمسيره
قلب موسكو فجرا اوقعتا اضرار في المباني
والشوارع المجاوره فضلا عن حاله الهلع
وفقدان الطمانينه في اوساط السكان جاء
الهجوم الجديد محملا ايضا بدلالات رمزيه
مهمه فاحدى المسيرتين تحطمت قرب وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه بينما اصابه الاخرى مركزا
للاعمال في احد شوارع موسكو الرئيسيه ثم
ان اوكرانيا تبنت الهجوم وهو امر نادر
الحدوث خلال هجمات سابقه استهدفت العمق
الروسي وموسكو تحديدا الجيش الروسي اعلن
اسقاط المسيارتين ووزاره الخارجيه اعتبرت
في بيان العمليه ارهابا واكدت احتفاظ
روسيا بحق اتخاذ اجراءات رد قاسيه
واشار البيان الى ان الدول الغربيه تقف
خلف افعال كيف وقد صرح نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن القومي الروسي
ان على روسيا انتقاء اهداف نوعيه وغير
متوقعه في اوكرانيا لضرباتها الانتقاميه
لا يعرف ما اذا كان استهداف موسكو جزءا من
الهجوم الاوكراني المضاد لكن من المعلوم
تماما ان الرئيس فولودو مرزلينسكي تعهد
برد على الضربات الروسيه على الاسبوع
الماضي وقد اعلنت قياده العمليات
الاوكرانيه في جنوب البلاد ان هجوما روسيا
جديدا بالمسيرات استهدف منشات في مرافق
منطقه اوديسا ودمر صومعه حبوب تطورات
عسكريه لكنها قد لا تنفصل عن قرار موسكو
بالانسحاب من اتفاق تصدير الحبوب
الاوكرانيه عبر البحر الاسود وفي شبه
جزيره القرم قصفت مسيرات اوكرانيه مستودع
ذخيره للجيش الروسي الذي اعلن ان قواته
اسقطت عده مسيرات اوكرانيه عبر انظمه
التشويش وبمضادات الطائرات
وعلى صعيد الحرب البريه قالت نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني ان قوات بلادها استعادت
نحو 230 كم مربعا من الجيش الروسي ضمن
هجومها المضاد الذي بداته منذ بضعه اسابيع
ومن تلك الاراضي المستعاده مساحات حول
مدينه باخموت واخرى شرق منطقه دونيس
من ينضم الان الينا فرانك لدودج كبير
الخبراء العسكريين في مؤسسه كلوب ساك
للدراسات اهلا وسهلا بك سيد لدوج ولنبدا
من هذا التبني الاخير لوزاره الدفاع
الاوكرانيه للهجوم في قلب موسكو ان يحدث
شيء مثل هذا في هذه المرحله من الحرب
ماذا نقرا فيه
مساء الخير لكم نعم من الاهميه بمكان ان
نرى ان وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه تبنت هذه
العمليه وكما اشرتم في تقريركم وفي
المقدمه شاهدنا سلسله من الهجمات على
اوديسا وكما اشرتم ايضا هناك هجوم قرب من
الحدود او المنطقه المحاذيه لرومانيا وهي
دوله تابعه لحلف شمال الاطلسي ان اوكرانيا
ارادت من خلال هذا الرد ان تخاطب الجمهور
الداخلي الشعب الاوكراني ان توضح الوزاره
وزاره الدفاع ان اوكرانيا باستطاعتها ان
ترد ولكن المشكله هي ان هذا الرد
وهذا الرد المضاد سوف يؤدي الى تصعيد
اضافي وهذا سوف يؤدي بالتالي الى محاوله
من قبل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
لمنع انفلات الامور عند الولايات المتحده
لديها بوعد قلق حقيقيه ازاء هذا التصعيد
الذي سلطتم الضوء عليه في تقريركم
وكانك يعني تلمح بامكانيه تدخل الولايات
المتحده في المرحله القادمه كيف يمكن ان
تتدخل وهي التي يعني تحفظت كثيرا
رغم وصول المعركه الى مراحل متقدمه في
اوقات سابقه ما الذي يمكن ان تفعله وكيف
اعتقد ان الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
تتحدث وتخاطب الان الاوكرانيين والمسؤولين
في الحكومه الاوكرانيه على المستويات
المختلفه على الارجح تسلط الضوء على اهميه
عدم التصعيد ولكن طبعا الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لا تحبذ قصف موسكو بشكل متكرر
ولكن طبعا كما ذكر التقرير هناك تهديدات
من الجانب الروسي كذلك اذا بدات التهديدات
في تصلوا الى بولندا على سبيل المثال
واعتقد ان الرساله هي لا تصعد في هذه
الحرب داخل الحدود الاوكرانيه اذا ما كنتم
تريدون ان تدعموا اوكرانيا فهذا الشيء
ولكن هجوم على موسكو هذا شيء اخر
اذا هل ترى تغيير بشكل سريع هل ترى
امكانيه تغيير في الاستراتيجيه الروسيه
هنا ايضا خصوصا اذا وضعنا عنوانها مثلا
منع تصدير الحبوب من الجانب الاوكراني هل
ستتغير هذه الاستراتيجيه كعنوان للحرب
الروسيه الان
بكل صراحه
[موسيقى]
صراحه كامله لقد شاهدنا الاستراتيجيه
الروسيه والتي تقضي بمنع الدوله
الاوكرانيه من ان يكون لديها استقلال وان
يكون لديها استقلاليه حتى اقتصاديه اذا ما
كانت هذه الاستراتيجيه هذه الاستراتيجيه
تنجح وفي هذا السياق نرى انسحاب روسيا من
مبادره الحبوب ما تود روسيا في حقيقه
الامر ان تقوم به وان تفرض الاتفاق على
اوكرانيا من خلال التهديد تهديد الاقتصاد
الاوكراني ولكن لا اعتقد ان اوكرانيا تود
ان تفاوض الان شكرا لك
كبير خبراء العسكريين في مؤسسه كلوبسك
الدراسات من
كثافه القذف الروسي على اوديسا تعيد تسليط
الضوء على اهميه المدينه التي توصف بانها
العاصمه الاقتصاديه والسياحيه لاوكرانيا
منذ ايام ومدينه اوديسا حاضره في واجهه
مشهد الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا تحديدا
منذ انتهاء العمل باتفاق نقل الحبوب عبر
البحر الاسود
مواقع حيويه وتاريخيه في المدينه استهدفت
بقصف روسي بالصواريخ والمسيرات وفق الجيش
الاوكراني اهمها موانئ وتصدير ومنشات
تخزين الحبوب وكاتدرائيه التجل التاريخيه
تعطيله موانئ اوديسا او منشاتها الزراعيه
ينهي او يقلل لحد كبير امكانيه استئناف
عمليات نقل الحبوب بحرا بمعزل عن روسيا
والاتفاق مع الاشاره الى روايه الجانب
الروسي القائله باستهداف قواته مواقع في
اوديسا جرى فيها تحضير هجمات بالزوارق
والطائرات المسيره استهدفت وقتها مواقع
حيويه في شبه جزيره القرم وكذلك جسرها
الاستراتيجي الذي يربطها بالاراضي الروسيه
قبل هذا المشهد المزدحم بالتفاصيل الحرب
كان لمدينه اوديسا اهميه كبيره فالمدينه
المطله على البحر الاسود توصف بانها
العاصمه الاقتصاديه والسياحيه يمتد ساحلها
عشرات الكيلومترات مما يسمح بوجود عدد من
الموانئ اهمها اوديسا ويوجني
وهي ثالث كبريات مدن اوكرانيا بعد كييف
ويسكنها اكثر من مليون شخص تحوي مطارا
دوريا ومنشات صناعيه وحقولا زراعيه وفيها
مصانع غاز النيون الذي يستخدم في صناعه
اشباه المو صلات اضافه لصناعات بتروليه
وكيميائيه تاسست اوديسا عام
1794 زمن الامبراطوره الروسيه كاترين
الثانيه فاصبحت في القرن التاسع عشر ثالث
اهم مدن الامبراطوريه بعد موسكو وسام
بيترسبورغ
اجرى رئيس مجلس الوزراء وزير الخارجيه
القطريه الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن الثني
اتصالا هاتفيا مع وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه
جرى خلال الاتصال استعراض العلاقات
الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين
ومناقشه مستجدات ازمه الحرب في اوكرانيا
اضافه الى تطورات الاوضاع في افغانستان
والسبل دعم الشعب الافغاني كما ناقش الشيخ
محمد بن عبد الرحمن الفاني مع بنكن اخر
مستجدات الاتفاق النووي الايراني
[موسيقى]
وكشفت ايضا وزاره الداخليه الجزائريه عن
شبه 97 حريقا في 16 ولايه اكبرها في
ولايات بجايه وجيجل والبويره شرقا وجنوب
العاصمه واضافت الداخليه الجزائريه ان
ارتفاع درجات الحراره وقوه الرياح ساهم في
اتساع رقعه الحرائق وان جهود الاطفاء سمحت
بالتحكم في عدد منها
هذه قريه بورباش في اعالي الاخضريه بولايه
البويره الشرق العاصمه الجزائريه هذه
الولايه اي البويره كانت واحده من
الولايات التي شهدت حرائق واسعه ليلى
الاحد الى الاثنين وخلفت عددا من القتلى
والجرحى يروي لنا شهود ان النيران حاصرتهم
في الرابعه صباحا من فجر اليوم واستمر
لهيب النيران في هذه القريه وفي محيطها
الى غايه منتصف نهار اليوم كان من الصعب
فيما يبدو على رجال الاطفاء الوصول الى
هذه القريه التي تحيط بها غابات كثيفه
وتقع في احد المرتفعات في اعالي منطقه
منطقه الاخضريه
كما تشاهدون اسفل القريه هناك ايضا غابات
تمتد على مد البصر ويمكن مشاهده السنه
النيران في بعض المواقد ولو ان الدخان
اكثر من النيران في هذه اللحظات التي تم
فيها اخماد هذه الحرائق وهناك فرق من
الحمايه المدنيه والدركه الجزائري
ومتطوعون من الهلال الاحمر الجزائري
يحاولون الوصول الى السكان اولا المتطوعين
الذين ما زالوا هنا يحرسون ممتلكاتهم
اذا هذا في الجزاء لما في تونس فقلت قوه
الدفاع المدني في محافظه جندوبه شمال غربي
البلاد انها اجلت جميع سكان منطقه ملوله
التابعه لمدينه طبرقه السياحيه وذلك بعد
اندلاع حريق في احدى الغابات في المنطقه
يبلغ عدد سكان المنطقه نحو الف شخص بحسب
احصاءات رسميه وكانت المنطقه شهدت الاسبوع
الماضي حريقا اتى على اجزاء كبيره من
الغابه قبل ان تسيطر عليه قوات الدفاع
المدني
هذا يوصل رجال الاطفاء مكافحه حرائق
الغابات الناجمه عن موجه الحر في اليونان
بعد اجلاء غير مسبوق لالاف السياح والسكان
المحليين من جزيرتي رودس وكورفو وفي
الاثناء قال رئيس الوزراء اليونانيين انه
لا يزال امام السلطات ثلاثه ايام صعبه في
مكافحه الحرائق وان البلاد في حرب على
الحرائق حسب تعبيره وقالت السلطات انها
اجلت اكثر من ثلاثين الف سائح من جزيره
رودز في اكبر عمليه من نوعها تشهدها
اليونان على الاطلاق وقد نقلت 16 الف شخص
عبر البر و 3000 عن طريق البحر كما اجلت
السلطات نحو الفين
وخمسمائه شخص من جزيره كورفو حيث حذرت
السلطات عبر رسائل على الهواتف حضرت
السكان والسياح من ضروره مغادره منازلهم
احتياطا
كما اظهرت صور اقمار صناعيه الانتشار
السريع لحرائق الغابات في جزيره رودس
اليونانيه وتظهر الصور الملتقطه يوم
الخميس منطقه محدوده من الحرائق في حين
اظهرت الصور يومي السبت والاحد مساحات
واسعه من الجزيره وقد احترقت غاباتها
وامتدت اعمده الدخان فوق بحر ايجه
وبعد قليل في فقره في المتابعه نلقي الضوء
على الضغوط القياسيه على شبكات الكهرباء
في دول عربيه وسط موجه الحر ونسال ضيف
الحصاد عن السبب في الانقطاعات المتزايده
للتيار الكهربائي
[موسيقى]
والى السودان الان حيث قال مراسل الجزيره
انفجارات متقطعه لاسلحه ثقيله دوت شمالي
ام درمان وذكر مراسل الجزيره ان الطائرات
الحربيه التابعه للجيش السوداني ظلت تحلق
منذ الصباح الباكر بصوره مكثفه في سماء
العاصمه
والتزامن مع ذلك سمعت اصوات اطلاق
المضادات الارضيه التابعه لقوات الدعم
السريع في مواقع مختلفه من العاصمه خصوصا
في جنوب ووسط ام درمان ووسط الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
وفي الاثناء افاد مصدر عسكري في الجيش
السوداني للجزيره ان دفاعات الجيش اسقطت
طائره المسيره تابعه للدعم السريع اثناء
هجوم على سلاح المهندسين في ام درمان
وقال فرحان حق النائب المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده ان نحو 19
مليونا يمثلون اكثر من اربعين في المئه من
سكان السودان يواجهون اليوم الجوع بسبب
الصراع الدائر حاليا في البلاد واضاف ان
المنظمه الدوليه وشركائها يواصلون بدل كل
ما في وسعهم للاستجابه للتداعيات
الانسانيه اللازمه للازمه
السودان واحد اكثر البلاد تعقيدا من حيث
الاستجابه الانسانيه في العالم في الوقت
الحالي مع ذلك نحن وشركائنا في المجال
الانساني نبذل قصار جهدنا للاستجابه
للازمه على الرغم من استمرار القتال
والقيود المفروضه على الوصول من جانبهم
يحذر البرنامج من ان اكثر من 40% من سكان
السودان اي اكثر من 19 مليون شخص يواجهون
الان الجوع بسبب الصراع
الى اسبانيا حيث اعرب زعيم الحزب الشعبي
المعارض البرتو نونيز فايخو الفائز في
الانتخابات التشريعات المبكره عن استعداده
لتشكيل الحكومات داعيا القوى السياسيه الى
عدم ادخال البلاد في حاله جمود سياسيه
ومن جانبه قال رئيس الحكومه الاسبانيه
وزعيم الحزب الاشتراكي تادروسان يتشاب لا
يرغب في تراجع عما وصفها بالمكاسب
الاجتماعيه والسياسيه
في استثناءات اسبانيا يحصل ان يفوز حزب في
الانتخابات التشريعيه دون التمكن من تشكيل
الحكومه ذلك هو التحدي الذي يواجه الحزب
الشعبي المعارض الذي فاز بوضوح لكنه لم
يحصل على الاغلبيه المطلقه
تعثر لم يمنع زعيمه من المطالبه بما يصفه
حقه في قياده اسبانيا في الولايه
التشريعيه المقبله
لكي تستمر سمعتنا الدوليه وامن
استثماراتنا يجب ان يكون رئيس الحكومه
المقبل هو الفائز في الانتخابات ببلد
يعتبر رابع قوه اقتصاديه في منطقه اليورو
مات يبدو انها لا تجد صدى لدى الاشتراكيين
الاسبان
[تصفيق]
اسبانيا كانت واضحه بشكل لا يحتمل الشك
الحلف الرجعي الذي كان يصبو اليه الغاء كل
التقدم الذي حققناه في السنوات الاخيره
فشل في مسعاه نحن نريد التقدم اسبانيا
اكثر بكثير
ومن بين هؤلاء الذين يعول عليهم بيدروسان
ثمه كوكبه من احزاب مختلفه الالوان اهمها
رفاق اليسار وقوميون يتوقعوا ان يرفعوا
سقف مطالبهم قبل تقديم مباركاتهم لزعيم
الاشتراكيين
دخلنا في اجواء الحيره
وهو ما يواجه المواطنه والاقتصاد وحتما
سيتاثر الاستقرار والصوره الدوليه
الاسبانيه تشكيل الحكومه بات صعبا لان
اليمين يفتقر الى الاغلبيه واليسار سيدفع
فاتوره باهظه لتشكيلها الى ان تتضح مواقف
معظم الاحزاب المشاركه في الانتخابات
التشريعيه يبدو ان تشكيل الحكومه المقبله
سيحتاج الى توافقات كبرى يبقى الحزب
الاشتراكي القوه السياسيه الوحيده القادره
على نسجها اما فشلوا هذه الفرضيه فيعني
توجه اسبانيا الى انتخابات اخرى ايمن
الزبير الجزيره مدريد
ومن مدريد ينضم الان الينا
الصحفي والمحلل السياسي اهلا وسهلا بك سيد
صبيان اذا الانتخابات الاسبانيه لم تفرز
اغلبيه مطلقه ما هو التحدي الاكبر الان
امام رئيس الحكومه المقبل
وايضا ان الحزب الشعبي والذي ربح في هذه
الانتخابات
هامش الربح في هذه الانتخابات هو محدود
للغايه وبالتالي لا يسمح لهذا الحزب بي ان
يشكل الحكومه لماذا ان
الحزب لديه الدعم اليمين المتطرف هذا
الحزب الشعبي لديه فقط دعم من اليمين
المتطرف وكلاهما اذا ما تحالف لا يمكنهما
ان يصل الى الاكثريه التي تؤدي بهم الى
التشكيل الحكومه في اسبانيا اذا اذا
البلاد مقبله السيد سبريان على مرحله
مفاوضات ربما مؤلمه وقاسيه
ما شكل التحالفات التي ترجحها انت هل
تتوقع مفاجات من نوع ما
في الحقيقه لا اعتقد اننا سوف نشهد مفاجات
كبيره في اسبانيا لان الفرق الاساسي
بالمقارنه مع الحكومه التي كانت لدينا منذ
اربع سنوات هو انه ومجددا في هذه الحاله
الحزب الاشتراكي يعتمد على
التحالفات
الاقليميه وهنا ياتي السيناريو المرتبط
بكتالونيا وهذا ما كان السيناريو عليه في
السنوات الاربع الماضيه توصل الطرفان الى
نوع من الاتفاق ونعرف بعد الاستئتاف
الاستئناف عفوا الذي حصل في كتالونيا
الوضع اختلف الان
والحزب الذي يطالب
بالاستقلال في كتالونيا عاد الى الساحه
اذا ما اراد بيدرو سانشي ز ان يحصل على
دعم هذا الحزب سوف يتعين عليه ان يوافق
وهذا شبه مستحيل اذا
كل
الامور تشير الى اننا ربما نشهد فتره من
الغموض ولربما نشهد انتخابات اضافيه
انتم في اسبانيا شكرا جزيلا لك
البحث والمحلل السياسي
تسببت الازمه الاقتصاديه التي يشهدها
لبنان منذ اربعه اعوام في ارتفاع كبير في
نسبه الاعتماد على التداول بالاوراق
النقديه في جميع المعاملات ياتي ذلك في ظل
تحذيرات دوليه من تحول لبنان الى اقتصاد
نقدي ما يرفع من مخاطر التبييض الاموال
وتسببوا بادراج لبنان على اللائحه
الرماديه للدول الخاضعه للرقبه
قياس وزن هذه الليرات بات اسهل من عدها
يجهزها وليد لدفع الرسوم المتوجبه عليه
مقابل ما يستورده من سيارات
لكن اتمام هذه العمليه اصبح عبئا ثقيله
وهذه مليارين وهذه مليارين او خمسه مليار
هول خمسه مليار جمرك سياره واحده
بدهم اياهم كاجو حملين اول شيء في خطر
الشاب اللي عم ينقله وخطر انه عم نحط
مصاري بالمكتب
بالصناديق اذا يحمل التجار ملياراتهم الى
مرفا بيروت
مليارات فقدت قيمتها نتيجه الازمه
الاقتصاديه وارتفاع سعر صرف الليره فضلا
عن ازمه الثقه في المصارف
ارباك الحاصل لا يقتصر على التجار وحسب بل
يصيب كل اللبنانيين في حياتهم اليوميه
سلع غذائيه ومنزليه بسيطه بات شرائها
يتطلب مئات الاوراق النقديه ما دفع معظم
المتاجر الى اعتماد التسعير بالدولار
تضخم منه طبيعي
يعني
ومع استبعاد اقتصاديين حذف الاصفار من
العمله اللبنانيه يناقش البرلمان تعديلات
قانونيه تسمح بطباعه فئات اكبر من الاوراق
النقديه
فالكتله النقديه تضخمت بشكل قياسي مع
استمرار المصرف المركزي بطباعه العمله
المحليه لتمويل نفقات الدوله ما دفع
الخبراء الى التحذير من مخاطر التحول
للاقتصاد النقدي
الاقتصاد النقدي بيزيد من امكانيه التهرب
الضريبي الناس عم تقبض كاش فيها متصرح هذا
الشيء بياثر على مداخيل الحكومه اللبنانيه
من جهه ومن جهه ثانيه بيزيد شبهات تبييض
الاموال وتمويل الارهاب في مبنى الجمارك
في مرفا بيروت تستوفى الرسوم بالليره
اللبنانيه فقط ما يتسبب في ازدحام يوميا
بهذا المكان وعند انقضاء النهار تتحول
غرفه الى مستودع للمبالغ المشبيه يعكس هذا
المشهد حجما الانهيار الذي اصاب العمله
اللبنانيه اوراق نقديه متداوله دون ضوابط
وسط تحضيرات مجموعه العمل المالي من ادراج
لبنان على القائمه الرماديه للدول الخاضعه
للرقابه خاصه ما لم ينجز المعالجات
المطلوبه في مهله السنه
كاترين حنه الجزيره بيروت
[موسيقى]
مع موجه الحاره الشديده التي تشهدها
المنطقه العربيه يشتد الطلب على الكهرباء
مما يزيد الضغط على شبكاتها وكنتيجه حتميه
لذلك تحدث انقطاعات في التيار الكهربائي
ويشهد سكان دول عربيه تعاني نزاعات مسلحه
او ازمات سياسيه مثل السودان واليمن
وفلسطين وسوريا انقطاعات يوميه للكهرباء
تمتد ساعات لبنان الذي يعاني المشكله
ذاتها يلجا كثير من مواطنيه لاستخدام
المولدات الكهربائيه لتامين ساعات اضافيه
بعد انقطاع الكهرباء الذي يتراوح ما بين
18 وعشرين ساعه يوميا مع ارتفاع درجات
الحراره اما في تونس فقد طلب الرئيس قيس
سعيد من المسؤولين في قطاع الكهرباء العمل
على وضع حد للانقطاع المتواصل للكهرباء في
عدد من جهات البلاد في اقرب الاجل ومن
المفارقات العربيه في هذا الصدد ان العراق
الذي يملك انتاجا ضخما من النفط
واحتياطيات لا باس بها من الغاز الطبيعي
يسجل عجزا في انتاج الكهرباء بنحو 13 الف
وتصل ساعات قطع التيار الكهربائي عن
العراقيين الى سته عشره ساعه يوميا
وتمثل مصر مفارقه اخرى تمكنت خلال الاعوام
الماضيه من تجاوز العجز في توليد الطاقه
الكهربائيه بفضل اكتشاف حقل جديدا للغاز
الطبيعي شرقي المتوسط ولكن مع بلوغ الطلب
على الكهرباء ذروته هذا الصيف شهدت مناطق
القاهره الكبرى وبورسعيد وسيناء واسوان
انقطاعات نادره للطياره الكهربائي استمرت
ساعات
سنناقش هذا الموضوع موضوع انقطاع تيار
كهربائي بهذا الشكل في هذا الحر الشديد في
كثير من الدول العربيه مع ضيفنا من عمان
عامر الشوبكي الخبير في شؤون النفط
والطاقه اهلا وسهلا بك استاذ عامر اين
يكمن الخلل برايك
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه ليلى لك
وللمشاهدين اعتقد بان يعني الارتفاع درجات
الحراره والحر ليس هو فقط السبب الوحيد
هنالك دول تعاني من انقطاعات ايضا بدون
وجود الحر الحر فاقم المشكله او اظهرها في
بعض الدول مثل تونس مثل مصر اللي انا دول
تعاني من هذه الانقطاعات قبل موجه الحر في
العراق في لبنان سوريا اليمن السودان
وايضا المفارقه ليست فقط في العراق ايضا
في ليبيا تملك مخزون الغاز وما زالت هنالك
انقطاعات في ليبيا في الكهرباء مع توفر
الغاز في احتياطيات ضخمه وربما مصدره ايضا
للغاز للقاره الاوروبيه فايضا الخلل يعني
هو في عدم وجود الحوكمه بالاساس في بنيه
تحتيه في ايجاد بنيه تحتيه تخدم مصلحه
البلاد عدم مراعاه نمو الطلب السنوي عدم
وجود صيانه لسواء للشبكات او لمحطات
التوليد عدم وجود استراتيجيه لتقدير
احتياجات البلد المستقبليه
وبالتاكيد الاطرابات السياسيه في بلدان
مثل اليمن
والعراق وسوريا تؤثر وفي السودان ايضا
تؤثر بعدم وجود البنيه التحتيه اصلا او
تدميرها في بعض الاحيان ايضا
سبب في كثير من هذه الدول طيب الان ما
هو ما المخرج من هذه الازمه التي لا يبدو
انها يعني اذا استمر الحركه كما هو عليه
وازداد الطلب على هذه الشبكات فالامر
يستفحل اكثر واكثر
نعم اقصد بالحق كما ايضا هو عدم يعني هو
الفساد بالتالي لعدم تطبيق الحوكمه نعم
الان الحلول تبدو الان الاوضاع اذا ما
استمرت على على ما هي عليه الان ايضا اكثر
سوءا في المستقبل نمو الطلب على الكهرباء
في العالم العربي يبلغ ضعف النمو طلب
العالمي متوسط تقريبا الان نمو الطلب
عربيا من سبعه الى عشره في العالم من
اربعه الى خمسه بالمئه نمو الطلب على
الكهرباء للفرد بالمتوسط مع هذا الامر ومع
البنيه التحتيه الموجوده الان وعدم وجود
استراتيجيات ثابته وعدم مراعاه امن التزود
بالطاقه وعدم وجود كفاءات حقيقيه تدير ملف
الطاقه في هذه البلدان بالتاكيد سنجد مزيد
من المعاناه في السنوات القادمه مثلا
هنالك دول استطعت القفز حول يعني على هذا
هذه المشكله مثل الجزائر مثل مصر
الان هي تتوفر لديها امكانيه يعني توليد
كهرباء تفوق 40% من حاجتها لكن عدم وجود
الوقود او الخلل في هذا الامر مع انه
محطات تبريد الكهرباء من المفروض ان يتم
تزويدها بمخزونك فيها 6 اشهر في الانقطاع
فهذه الخلل ولد المشكله مثلا في مصر ام
بعض بلدان اخرى يبدو مستقبلها غامضا لعدم
وجود اصلا خطه لاصلاح الشبكه الكهربائيه
او محطات التوليد طبعا يبدو ان المواطنين
عاديين يجدون لنفسهم مخرجا من خلال
المولدات ولكن يعني هل هذا حال يعني هل
هذا هو
حل في دول حديثه المفتاح بناء دول حديثه
يعني الى متى سيستمر هذا هذا يعني هذا هو
الحل المؤقت اللي يعني مثل مسكن
نعم لكن هذه هذه هذا حلول المجبرين عليه
السكان المولدات لكن المولدات الان اصبحت
جزء من المشكله لانه اصحاب المولدات اصبح
لديهم نفوذ ويحاولون تعطيل بناء محطات
التوليد لكي تستمر مصالحهم وابواب ارزاقهم
الحلول الافضل هي في الطاقه المتجدده
للبلدان التي قد لا تستطيع الاعتماد على
حكوماتها في البنيه التحتيه للكهرباء وهذا
حصل نوعا ما عند الكثيرين في اليمن
تجدينهم يركبون الطاقه الشمسيه على
المنازل رغم انها متذبذبه متقطعه تحتاج
الى بطاريات وغير اعتماديه الا انها احد
الحلول المؤقته للمرور من هذه الازمه مع
عدم توفر الخدمه من الدوله او الحكومه نعم
اشكرك استاذ عامر الشبكه الخبير في شؤون
النفط والطاقه
[موسيقى]
وسنستمر مع موضوع الكهرباء هناك كبار هناك
عجائز هناك مرضى انا من الذين يتضررون
بشده اذا انقطعت الكهرباء هذا ما تقوله
السودانيه نعمات اسحاق والتي تعيش في
بورسودان حيث تسبب انقطاع المياه
والكهرباء لفترات طويله في تفاقم معاناه
سكان المدينه الذين يتعرضون ايضا لموجات
حر شديد يمكن ان تصل درجه الحراره في
بورسودان الواقعه في شرق البلاد مثلا الى
اثنتين وخمسين درجه مئويه في الصيف ويقول
السكان انقطاع المياه مستمر منذ نحو سته
اشهر ورغم معاناه المدينه التي لجا اليها
الاف السودانيين بحثا عن الامان تختم
نعمات اسحاق حديثها بالقول نحمد الله
ونكون من العباد الشاكرين ومعها نقول
الامل كل الامل ان تتراجع الصراعات عبر
العالم ويعم السلام هو لكن دعونا نمسك
بطرف الخيط من حديث نعمات الصابره رغم
المعاناه ونتمسك دائما بالحلم والامل
شكرا لكم
[موسيقى]